[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance for days at a time through
this wretched presidency the topic of
Trump's apparent conspiracy with Russia
to get himself elected has actually
disappeared from the public dialogue
sessions Flynn Trump jr. mana Ford
Kushner Embassy's signal intelligence
kiss lyac Carter Paige Comey Muller
bezel mitts kyuf Roger stone steel Gucci
42.0 Assange
Kalugin Gorka noonas Bannon Cambridge
analytic Putin all of them periodically
crowded off the front pages of your mind
and yet somehow always we come back to
Russia and we come back to it almost
solely almost exclusively almost
entirely because of the dedication and
the single mindedness of one man Donald
Trump's worst enemy on the subject of
Russia Donald Trump moreover because
Trump cannot stop reminding us of it we
keep coming back to one specific part of
the Russia story that few people besides
him seem to take seriously or even think
is relevant the PP tape Saturday morning
he retweeted the link to what even Fox
News treated as a trivial aside of a
story he added quote in other words
Russia was against Trump in the 2016
election yeah that's not only not true
and not in that story but most
importantly of all that story had gone
unnoticed unnoticed just as the entire
Russia story had gone unnoticed since it
had peaked eight days earlier with the
revelations of Sergei Kissel ax reported
claim that he talked about the election
campaign with sessions and then Trump's
pissy abusive sessions on Twitter we
weren't talking about Trump and Russia
we were talking about how Trump told the
Boy Scouts a story about party yachts
and encouraged them to boo Barack Obama
and thank them for voting for him Trump
told the cops of this station they
should resume police brutality he
invoked the ethnic slur paddy wagon
Trump claimed human trafficking may be
worse now than it's ever been in his
history of the world like we didn't
import slaves into this country as
recently as July 9th 1860 had his chief
of staff get off Air Force One
and into the presidential motorcade
while he himself stayed behind on the
plane and tweeted out that he had a new
chief of staff Trump announced a ban of
transgendered troops from the military
without first consulting anybody who
runs the military apparently to try to
save a few million dollars with which to
build an estimated 74 miles of his
goddamned wall Trump threatened Senator
Murkowski and all but ignored Senator
McCain and promptly lost on Obamacare
again because of the votes of Senator
Murkowski and Senator McCain and Trump
got a new communications director who
helped to oust the old chief of staff
and the first day the new chief of staff
showed up for work
he helped fire the new communications
director the police had had to apologize
for Trump the Boy Scouts had had to
apologize for Trump the Department of
Defense all but had to apologize for
Trump all this had happened since the
last major development on Russia so much
you could not process it all not an
avalanche not a hurricane not the great
Boston molasses flood of 1919 but more
like a sharknado of impossible to
believe news stories wiping Russia off
the map of consciousness and who puts it
back on that map with a big red line
under the part about the PP tape Trump
did he reminded everybody about Russia
not by retweeting just a generic story
about Russia that he mistakenly thinks
somehow exonerates him he did this by
retweeting a story about Russia a day
old at the time he retweeted it would
mainlining back to the thing that
obsesses him and which he must disprove
to everyone in the world and which
drives him the craziest about the Russia
story not the conspiracy not the
treachery not the treason not how stupid
his son and son-in-law are the story he
retweeted includes the report about the
PP tape firm behind anti-trump dossier
also worked for Russia Senate witness
says I mean even fox only gave it a
thousand words on its website in short
on its face it is a disputed and denied
claim
that the company fusion GPS not only
served as a middleman in the production
of the steel dossier about Trump but
also worked for Russia against the US
human rights law of the global Magnitsky
Act not even the man making the claim
ties those two things together but Trump
apologists are trying to make it seem as
if this story means the Russians are
behind the steel dossier
but Trump tweeted the link to it
presumably because it casts doubt on the
steel dossier the steel dossier their
steel dossier the steel dossier what's
in the steel dossier the PP tape January
6th James Comey brings up the quote
salacious parts of the dossier to trump
the PP tape Trump denies it and quoting
Comey
expressed his disgust for the
allegations January 27th when Trump
invited Comey to dinner
Comey says Trump brought up the dossier
again and the tape and again expressed
his disgust so he was thinking of
ordering Comey to investigate to prove
the tape didn't happen March 30th Comey
says Trump phoned him to tell him he
quote had not been involved with hookers
in Russia July 29th Trump retweets a day
old story that might by extension kind
of almost sort of cast suspicions on the
steel dossier as if steel himself had
not written it was raw data and much of
it unsubstantiated so why does Trump
keep bringing us back to the dossier and
the mm-hmm tape why when weeks and even
months go by without a real reference to
the tape or even the steel dossier why
does he virtually stand in front of us
erase all the other headlines and
symbolically hold up a VHS tape and say
see there's nothing on this tape I'm not
on this tape there's nothing to this
tape this tape this tape Boy Scouts
scare Moochie hired scare emoji fired
paddy wagons transgendered troops
Priebus repeal and replace McCain
Bukowski and go banning yourself all of
it in roughly one week filling the
airwaves consuming the Internet breaking
Twitter
cause II the Russia story the dossier
the tape - all recede into the darkness
and Donald Trump just pulled it back out
and put up twenty seven more spotlights
on it to make sure the PP tape story
doesn't dry up resist remove Pease